Since appearing in 1984, Freddy Krueger has
become an iconic horror villain.
But how did he go from a child killer in a
grimy Christmas sweater to Jason Voorhees'
puppeteer?
Here's the breakdown of the entire, original
Nightmare on Elm Street story.
Our first real introduction to Freddy Krueger
comes in the form of a dream that high schooler
Tina has one terrible night.
She later shares the experience with her friends,
Nancy, Glen, and Rod, who have all been having
the same dreams about the same man.
It's soon revealed that the monster in their
dreams was once a human child killer who became
the target of the town's parents after the
legal system failed to bring him to justice.
"But he can't get you now.
He's dead, honey, because mommy killed him."
Somehow, Krueger figured out how to live on
in the dream world, and now he wants to murder
the children of the parents who killed him.
Luckily, Nancy eventually defeats him after
dragging him into the real world.
After their confrontation, Nancy walks outside
her house, and all seems well.
Her friends are alive, and everything is sunshine
and roses … until the car suddenly turns
into a Freddy-mobile and traps everyone inside.
Five years later, in Freddy's Revenge, a kid
named Jesse and his family move into Nancy's
old house on Elm Street, and an entirely new
cast of characters are tormented by Freddy.
Jesse's dreams of Freddy are a little different
from Nancy's, in that Jesse never really finds
himself in any danger of being killed.
But when he and his friend, Lisa, find Nancy's
old diary, he realizes exactly who he's up
against.
In order to stay awake, Jesse starts to wander
around town at night.
He winds up in an S&M bar, where his leather-clad
gym coach catches him drinking a beer and
takes him back to the school to punish him.
There, Jesse experiences his first Freddy
possession, and he slashes his teacher to
death in the showers.
Things come to a head at Lisa's pool party,
where Freddy actually bursts through Jesse's
stomach, kills his friend, and then goes after
everyone at the pool.
Lisa tells Freddy that she loves Jesse and
kisses him, which prompts Freddy to burst
into flames.
A Nightmare on Elm Street 3: Dream Warriors
brings Nancy back to the franchise, only now
she's an intern therapist at a psychiatric
hospital.
Also at the hospital is Kristen, a teenager
who has the ability to bring other people
into her own dreams, which comes in handy
when fighting Freddy.
It's during this movie that a nun named Sister
Mary Helena reveals that the only way to defeat
Freddy is to find his remains and bury them
on hallowed ground.
Nancy becomes Freddy's final victim before
his bones are able to finally be put to rest,
destroying his monstrous form in the real
world.
And how's this for a plot twist?
That helpful nun was Freddy's mom all along.
A year later, in Nightmare on Elm Street 5
: The Dream Master, Dream Warrior Kristen
is convinced that Freddy Krueger is still
out there and looking to take down her and
her friends, since that's kind of his thing.
As it turns out, he is.
After killing the other two Dream Warriors
survivors, Freddy takes aim at Kristen's new
friends, including a girl named Alice who
knows a powerful rhyme called "The Dream Master."
Freddy finally kills Kristen, but before she
dies, she's able to pass her dream power on
to Alice.
Alice confronts Freddy, and remembering "The
Dream Master" rhyme, she shows the monster
his reflection.
"And it shall die!"
Defeated, Freddy is torn apart by the very
souls he'd trapped, releasing the ghost of
every trapped, murdered child.
In Nightmare on Elm Street 5 : The Dream Child,
Alice discovers she's pregnant.
But this isn't your average pregnancy.
Freddy is somehow feeding her baby with the
souls of his victims.
Through all of this, Alice keeps seeing a
young boy named Jacob, who turns out to be
an older version of her unborn child.
Alice discovers that the body of Freddy's
mother, Amanda, is still in the asylum, and
now, the only way to defeat Freddy is to release
Amanda's soul.
After a little trickery by young Dream Child
Jacob, Amanda and Jacob are able to trap Freddy's
soul...by turning him into an adorable baby.
In Freddy's Dead : The Final Nightmare, a
decade has passed, and in Springwood, Ohio,
the entire population of minors has been mysteriously
wiped out.
Only one remains, John Doe, who Freddy sends
out into the world in order to retrieve more
souls for him.
Outside of the city, John comes across a youth
shelter, where he meets Maggie and a new group
of future victims.
John and Maggie have dreams involving the
same little girl, which drives them back to
Springwood.
John, Maggie, and the other teens take refuge
at the old Elm Street house, where Freddy
attacks each one.
Maggie eventually realizes that Freddy is
actually her father.
"I know who I am."
"You're my blood.
Only you could have brought me out."
With the help of another shelter employee
named Doc, it's discovered that Freddy has
been kept alive by dream demons, and the only
way to kill him once and for all is to drag
him into the real world.
Maggie brings him into the real world and
throws a bunch of weapons at him in 3D, then
stabs him with his own glove... and blows
him up.
In Freddy vs. Jason, it's become clear to
Freddy that the only way to make a real comeback
is if the teenage residents of Springwood
remember how terrifying he is.
Freddy decides to resurrect Jason Voorhees
so the mask-wearing murderer can kill a bunch
of kids in Freddy's name.
Things go mostly as planned as Jason goes
after local girl Lori and her friends.
At a party in a corn field, Jason goes all
out, not only satiating his own relentless
desire to kill, but taking all the fun out
of it for Freddy, as well.
While Lori and her friends try to figure out
a way to kill both monsters, Freddy becomes
increasingly more annoyed with Jason's inability
to be controlled.
Lori figures out how to pull Freddy into the
real world, and Krueger and Voorhees face
off in the horror fight of the century.
Wes Craven's New Nightmare isn't exactly part
of the continuity, but there are enough nods
to the original franchise that its presence
in the timeline makes sense.
Essentially, it takes place in the real world,
and Heather Langenkamp and Robert Englund
play themselves, actors who've been offered
roles in a new Nightmare on Elm Street movie.
However, the world of Nightmare starts creeping
into Heather's real life.
Her sleepwalking son Dylan has dreams of Freddy.
After he kills Heather's husband, Demon Freddy
goes after Dylan and the only person who can
stop him is Heather as Nancy.
Heather plays the part and goes to the Elm
Street house, where Demon Freddy has Dylan
held captive.
With Dylan's help, Heather eventually manages
to overpower Demon Freddy and locks him in
a furnace, where he burns to death.
Considering that the next Nightmare film was
a full-on reboot, it looks like this death
finally took for old Freddy Krueger.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.